20 teachers were asked
about their favorite course.
7 teachers said language.
3 teachers said history.
9 teachers said geometry.
1 teacher said chemistry.
0 teachers said physics.
Create a bar chart showing
everyone's favorite courses.
So we've got the bar
chart right over here.
And let's see what
we need to plot.
So it said, 0
teachers said physics,
which is surprising
to me since physics
is arguably my favorite course.
But let's plot
what the data has.
So physics-- so right now
it looks like it's halfway
between 0 and 1, so
you actually have
to bring the physics down to 0.
Let's see, chemistry.
Let's see, 1 teacher
said chemistry,
so we got to bring
chemistry up to 1.
Now, 9 teachers said geometry.
So geometry, let's
bring that up to nine.
1 teacher said chemistry.
Oh, I already read that.
History.
3 teachers said history, so
let's bring history up to 3.
And then language.
7 teachers said language,
so let's move this up to 7.
And I think if I didn't
make any careless mistakes,
we should be done.
Yep.
Very good.